Anyone retiring from the coal-mines of life,
might have noticed an ever growing defacement.
Their noses and ears appear to be bigger.
In fact, they are.
There is a common misconception this growth
is due to cartilage continuing to grow as
you age.
In reality, this isn’t true.
The real reason our noses and ears keep growing
is the result of that red-headed-stepchild
of fundamental forces, gravity.
To understand why our facial protrusions begin
to make us look like Pinocchio caught red-handed,
let’s break apart what cartilage actually
is, how it grows, and why it sags over time.
Cartilage is connective tissue coming in three
forms: Hyaline, Elastic, and Fibrocartilage.
The three main components of all cartilage
types are: cells called chondrocytes, elastin
fibers, and an intercellular matrix material.
The difference between the three types lies
in the kinds of protein fiber and their amounts
embedded within the matrix.
Hyaline cartilage (also called articular)
contains large protein molecules, like collagen,
making up its matrix.
This matrix is the predominant material within
hyaline cartilage.
It’s the most common throughout the body,
found in your joints and on the edge of your
ribs.
This is also the type responsible for the
shape of your sizable sniffer.
Elastic cartilage has large amounts of the
same matrix material as hyaline, but its main
component is elastic fibers that give it more
flexibility.
This type of cartilage is responsible for
your ears.
It’s also found in your epiglottis (the
flap that keeps your food and drink from going
down your lungs), and in the tubes between
your ears and mouth, called Eustachian tubes.
spine1Fibrocartilage is exactly what the name
implies, mostly fibers.
Unlike hyaline cartilage’s uniform structure,
the fibers in this type of cartilage are more
open and have a spongy-like architecture.
This makes them perfect for shock absorption.
As such, you can find them between your vertebrae,
and in the joints of your knee, shoulders,
and mandible.
All types of cartilage grow in one of two
ways; interstitial, and appositional.
Interstitial growth happens when cartilage
is formed by chondrocytes within the cartilage,
forming additional matrix.
Appositional growth happens by adding new
cartilage on the surface.
This is formed from chondrocytes in a dense
layer of connective tissue surrounding the
cartilage, called the perichondrium.
The question then becomes: does this interstitial
and appositional growth, cause the mass of
our cartilage, and its size, to increase as
we age?
The result being bigger ears and noses.
The answer is no.
Studies have shown the numbers of cells present
in our cartilage is very similar up to the
age of 40.
After that, we actually have a significantly
lower number of cells present here- specifically,
1.8 times lower.
The misconception that cartilage continues
to grow in size throughout our lifetime is
mainly attributed to the growth in sharks.
Sharks skeletal structure is mostly cartilage
and they do continue growing throughout their
lives.
Fortunately for us, this doesn’t happen
in humans.
old-manAs mentioned before, the actual cause
of our seemingly-swelling snout is gravity.
When we age, the collagen and elastin fibers
that make up cartilage begin to break down.
This causes them to stretch and sag, making
them appear longer.
Our skin giving structural support to cartilage
also contains collagen and elastin fibers
that droop over time.
This compounds the lengthening problem.
Drooping isn’t the only cause to the appearance
of larger ears and noses.
The surrounding areas of the face, like your
cheeks and lips, lose volume over time.
The result is the appearance of larger organs
next to them.
Similar to the time honored tradition of standing
next to someone who looks worse then you when
trying to hit on a prospective mate.
It makes you look better!
All of this drooping and stretching does cause
our ears and noses to lengthen.
Studies have shown that ears elongate by .22
millimeters per year.
This elongation-to-age ratio is so exacting,
it can be used by forensic scientists to determine
the approximate age of a person.